SEAN ROBINSON: Oftentimes
the tasks we give students
in the lab are really complex.
They may not have
all the background
they need in order to
complete the task when
they're starting it.
That level of
uncertainty really causes
some anxiety in the
students, and can be
a barrier for their learning.
But if you're a professional
scientist, this type of anxiety
is something you're
actually very familiar with.
Most of us really
don't know what
we're doing when we start
a new research project.
I find it very useful to
notice when a student is
in that condition, and call
it out, and actually explain
how this is actually
a very normal thing.
This is not them being
in a state of failure.
This is them actually
feeling like what
a real scientist feels like.
A major part of a
course like this
is building up the students'
identity as a scientist,
helping them move their
understanding of themselves
from being a physics student
to being a physicist.
If we can achieve that by
the end of the semester,
then this course is
a complete success,
even if they've learned not
a single thing about quantum
mechanics or relativity.